en su encuentro con majuda base en
ramala Anthony blinken reiteró el
llamado a desescalar las tensiones tras
semanas de Gran violencia con 35
palestinos muertos en sijordania Solo
este enero y siete israelíes muertos en
un ataque a la salida de una sinagoga en
Jerusalén el secretario de estado
estadounidense señaló que los palestinos
están perdiendo sus esperanzas y por eso
reiteró como ayer como Benjamín netania
que ninguna parte debe tomar medidas es
que se alejen de una solución de dos
estados de ahí que ratificara la
oposición de Estados Unidos a la
expansión de los asentamientos israelíes
en sijordania ocupada a las demoliciones
y desalojos de palestinos y a las
acciones que violen el status quo de los
lugares sagrados y fuera de las palabras
Solo dos anuncios 50 millones de dólares
adicionales para la agencia de la ONU
para los refugiados o de palestinos y un
acuerdo para proporcionar telefonía 4G a
los palestinos algo habitual en cada
visita estadounidense por su parte el
presidente de la Palestina Aunque
desacreditado en estos momentos
responsabilizó a Israel de cualquier
escalada y dijo estar dispuesto a
trabajar con Washington y la comunidad
internacional para restablecer el
diálogo político ninguno de los dos hizo
referencia al menos en público a un
restablecimiento de la cooperación en
seguridad entre Israel y la autoridad
Palestina recordemos que a base de
suspendió esta comunicación tras la
redada letal en el jueves Aunque según
prensa israelí que se basa en otra cita
de avance con el director de la Cia este
corte sería solo parcial así concluye la
cuarta gira de blinker en la región que
no dio pasos concretos para rebajar la
violencia y que en cambio se encontró
tanto en ramala como en gaza con algunas
protestas de palestinos que ya han
dejado de ver a Estados Unidos como un
interlocutor válido